[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face aux territoires sur tv5monde en
direct avec nos partenaires de la presse
quotidienne régionale ouest france vous
pouvez regarder cette émission sur ouest
france.fr sur nicematin.com sur
franceantilles.fr avec un léger décalage
dû aux fuseaux horaires évidemment aux
antilles sur lamontagne.fr également et
sur 20minutes.fr donc ce qu'on appelle
en repli mon invité ce matin céline
d'algos bonjour anne hidalgo jours à
josette maire de paris une ligne or et
vous êtes candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
l'actualité c'est en ukraine avec une
opération militaire là-bas explosion
dans plusieurs grandes villes les
bourses européennes
s'effondre actuellement alors la
question c'est votre réaction bien sûr à
cette intervention militaire en ukraine
mais également une deuxième question car
sans véritable expérience internationale
sans vous faire offense comment une
candidate comme vous anne hidalgo va
appréhender cette campagne ce qui a pas
un véritable tournant est ce que vous
pouvez exister comment pouvez vous être
audible et surtout face au président
sortant s'il est candidat je pense qu'il
le sera comment vous pouvez exister
d'abord peut-être tout de la situation
en ukraine la condamnation ferme que je
fais que j'ai fait dès hier de
l'attitude du président poutine qui est
responsable de cette situation de cette
escalade ils en portent l'entière
responsabilité je tiens à le dire ici et
bien sûr que face à cette situation il
faut de l'unité de l'unité européenne et
de l'unité nationale vous avez raison
cette guerre en europe est une donnée
nouvelle une donne est grave dramatique
d'ailleurs qui amène aussi dans cette
campagne à se positionner par rapport à
cet enjeu européen est interne à 10 à
votre sujet une expérience
internationale actuelle et je suis sans
doute une de celles parmi les candidats
et les candidates qui est la plus grande
expérience de recevoir la dignité récent
jury mairie de paris c'est suffisant ça
n'est pas exactement ce que j'ai fait
me suis pas contenté de cela je me suis
très très largement investi dans la
diplomatie internationale la diplomatie
des villes reconnu d'ailleurs par toutes
les instances internationales que ce
soit l'onu l'osce et des oeufs dont j'ai
été une des ambassadrices donc les
questions internationales je suis une
des rares à les connaître et à les avoir
pratiqués et avoir pu réagir et les tue
tous les jeux les militaires et la géo
plomer lille et le militaire des cibles
parce que justement vous savez c'est un
avantage à être maire de paris c'est
justement que on a un positionnement qui
est un positionnement qui sur ces
questions militaires géostratégique fait
que j'ai une connaissance très précise
des questions de défense et des
questions géopolitiques deuxièmement
quand même que doit faire aujourd'hui
l'europe face à cette guerre qui vient
d'être déclarée vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
un pays allié je pense que la question
qui est posée là maintenant sur la table
et celle d'aider d'accompagner l'ukraine
dans l'armement qui doit être le sien
poutine ne connaît que le rapport de
force si on veut la paix il faut bien
sûr donner les moyens à l'ukraine de
pouvoir se défendre ça c'est la première
position que je défendrai au niveau
européen enfin je tiens à vous dire
aussi parce que cette guerre en europe
va avoir des conséquences vous l'avez
dit l'effondrement des bourses seulement
mais des marchés mondiaux et européens
je sais qu'il va y avoir si la menace
d'embargo sur le gaz est mise à
exécution par poutine qu'il y aura des
conséquences aussi sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français je demande au
gouvernement d'anticiper au gouvernement
français d'anticiper et de prévoir là
aussi un blocage des prix qui fasse que
cette guerre n'est parlement d'autre
conséquence un blocage aux prix somme
voilà et surtout surtout je le redis
qu'il y ait une unité la campagne ne va
pas pouvoir se tenir exactement dans les
mêmes conditions je suis heureuse
d'avoir vu que certains candidats je
pense à l'extrême droite et je pense
aussi à jean luc mélenchon qui il y a
deux jours condamné l'otan condamne
aujourd'hui cette guerre enclenchée par
poutine c'est très bien mais je pense
que il vaut mieux là maintenant créer
une véritable unité pour aller vers la
défense de nos amis ukrainiens mais
aussi évidemment de l'europe et de
l'europe de la dcn hidalgo la maire de
paris candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui est notre invité ce
matin sur face aux territoires voici
françois xavier le franc de ouest france
dans un instant
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir série lefranc bonjour
bonjour la sauce matin plusieurs gauches
au programme l'interview que vous
souhaitiez réalisé d'anne hidalgo oui
bonjour madame hidalgo bouge alors il ya
beaucoup de candidats de gauche la
gauche donne l'image d'un monde vraiment
éclaté est ce que la notion d'union de
la gauche qui est une notion ancienne a
encore du sens aujourd'hui quand on voit
qu'il y a tant de différence sur tant de
sujets entre tous les candidats qui se
réclament de gauche n'en sais quoi de
gauche aujourd'hui bien sûr que la
gauche est aujourd'hui éclatée que vous
avez une gauche jean luc mélenchon une
extrême gauche qui considère que son
principal objectif c'est de tuer la
gauche de gouvernement celle que je
représente qui est dans cette obsession
depuis très longtemps et paradoxalement
pour quelqu'un quand même comme jean luc
mélenchon qui a été largement nourrie au
mandat de cette gauche de gouvernement
et puis il y à aussi bien sur des alliés
des partenaires avec lesquels nous avons
des différences mais avec lesquels nous
gouvernent je pense évidemment aux verts
je pense aussi à nos alliés communistes
avec lesquels nous gouvernons notamment
c'est le cas à paris mais dans beaucoup
d'autres collectivités qu'est ce que
nous devons proposer aujourd'hui et sur
quoi nous pouvons réunir les français
bien au delà de la gauche puisque moi la
couche que j'incarne c'est cette gauche
de responsabilité de gouvernement cette
gauche qui est capable de réunir les
français depuis le centre jusque et le
pouvoir d'achat la gauche de pouvoir
d'achat c'est une question centrale les
inégalement pouvant aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens ont du mal à joindre
les deux bouts le prix de l'énergie
augmentent on a parlé est ce que la
gauche a pas casser le lien avec ces
gens là qu'est ce que on peut dire à des
électeurs de gauche très déçu
aujourd'hui de voir ce spectacle qui
souffrent dans leur quotidien qui ont
envie d'exprimer les choses qui parfois
n'ont même plus envie de voter qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour leur faire
comprendre que dans cette campagne a
peut-être des idées intéressantes et
comment comment surtout leur faire
comprendre qu'il y ait un tel éclatement
la gauche surtout leur faire comprendre
que s'ils votent à droite à l'extrême
droite et s'ils votent pour emmanuel
macron qui est de droite leur situation
en termes de pouvoir d'achat ne va pas
s'améliorer puisque cette situation
qu'ils connaissent et notamment ces cinq
dernières années on était cinq années
pendant lesquelles les inégalités ont
beaucoup progressé dans notre pays les
salaires ont stagné et les revenus des
plus riches des plus fortunés ont
commencé en continuer à augmenter donc
bien sûr que si on continue à se dire le
problème c'est l'union de la gauche sans
regarder les propositions des candidats
les propositions que je fais c'est quoi
c'est de dire oui il ya un problème
d'inégalité ya un problème de salaires
trop faibles donc est ce qu'on fait et
ça c'est ce que d'ailleurs la gauche a
toujours fait quand elle est arrivée au
gouvernement d'abord augmenter les
salaires augmenter le smic parce que et
de 15% ça veut dire 200 euros par mois
et puis faire des négociations parce que
je crois à la négociation je crois au
dialogue social des négociations dans
toutes les branches dans les entreprises
pour réhausser le niveau de salaire
parce que la question du pouvoir d'achat
elle se règlent d'abord par la question
du salaire et elle se règle aussi par
une redistribution beaucoup plus juste
des richesses produites dans le pays
alors un peu l'histoire en 1977 ça ne
nous rajeunit pas le parti socialiste
avait conquis beaucoup de villes ont
parlé du socialisme municipal et quatre
ans après françois mitterrand arrivé à
l'elysée vous avez voulu asseoir votre
campagne sur des mers mais vous avez
c'est le canadien réseau de mères qui
travaillent avec vous comment est ce que
vous allez dans votre campagne reste
quelques semaines là ça va être court il
reste quelques semaines comment est ce
que vous allez poser la question des
territoires la question locale la
question de la proximité dans un monde
compliqué on le voit avec cette guerre
qui démarre ce matin d'abord cette
question de la proximité le rôle des
maires qui ont été vraiment en première
ligne sur toutes les crises la crise
sanitaire la crise démocratique la crise
des gilets jaunes qui a été là pour
organiser les débats les maires donc les
maires et cette proximité est
indispensable pour faire respirer notre
démocratie et trouver les bonnes
solutions à l'échelle locale des
solutions d'emplois des solutions
d'éducation donc comment faire et bien
dire aux françaises et aux français
qu'il sorte de cette idée qu'il y aurait
une fatalité a continué à foncer dans le
mur comme on est en train de le faire
qu'ils prennent leur avenir en main
qu'ils prennent leurs décisions bien sûr
que la gauche de gouvernement n'est pas
parfaite bien sûr qu'on a fait des
bêtises bien sûr qu'il ya des choses
qu'on n'a pas réussi mais quand même
cette gauche de gouvernement que
j'incarne est partout sur les
territoires où nous dirigeons avec mes
amis cette équipe de france des marques
que nous faisons et ce que des
politiques plus solidaire des politiques
plus actifs sur le plan économique et
des politiques en faveur de la jeunesse
et de l'environnement comment est ce que
le maire vous êtes la maire de paris
dans un pays très centralisé
comment est ce que vous allez prendre en
compte l'extraordinaire diversité des
territoires français parce que c'est
aussi ça une lune une des chances de la
france cette diversité mais comment est
elle prise en compte par vous-même dans
cette campagne d'abord je connais mon
pays je ne suis pas née à paris je n'ai
pas grandi à paris j'ai aussi comme
beaucoup de parisiens cette vie je
dirais des régions que je connais très
bien j'ai grandi à lyon j'ai grandi dans
un quartier qui s'appelle la duchère qui
est un quartier de lyon un quartier dit
difficile et par ailleurs vous savez
être maire de paris c'est quoi c'est
être maire d'une ville la capitale de la
france certes mais qui a conquis sa
liberté et qui a conquis son pouvoir le
pouvoir des citoyens de paris face au
pouvoir central donc moi la
décentralisation et le fait que les
territoires doivent plus leurs cornes
pas très fort aujourd'hui alors il
réforme une grande réforme de la
décentralisation évidemment parce que
emmanuel macron a été un monarque
républicain il a décidé de tout tout
seul tout le temps y compris pendant la
crise sanitaire et ils à infantiliser
les français il s'est assis sur tous les
corps intermédiaires et surtout les élus
locaux donc donné on ne donne rien de
région de donner des moyens non je
donner des moyens à toutes les communes
aux régions aux départements plus de le
voir bien sûr parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
savez l'état ne compense même pas les
transferts de compétences qui l'a fait
vis-à-vis des départements des communes
et donc il faut absolument si on veut
une efficacité de l'action publique et
des services publics il faut passer par
la proximité donc j'engagerai une très
très grande étape de décentralisation
comme de fer l'avait fait en 82 on va
bientôt fêter les 40 ans de la loi là le
maire de paris candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui est notre invité
aujourd'hui fo condamne ans anne hidalgo
sébastien gros mètres de ouest france
françois xavier le franc a rencontré une
jeune fille elle s'appelle morgan le g
soyons très pragmatique elle a des
difficultés de logement il lui répondit
je constate que depuis lâché sanitaires
il devient de plus en plus difficile
pour nous de se loger en campagne suite
certainement la migration des métropoles
dans nos campagnes et les prix
l'éloigner deviennent exorbitants les
conditions d'accès aux
logements locatifs sont complètement
improbable que comptez vous faire pour
changer ça et faciliter l'accès au
logement pour pour les gens comme moi
qui ne veulent pas devenir propriétaire
d'abord construire plus de logements la
construction de logements s'est effondré
en france et je veux construire plus de
logements cent cinquante mille logements
dont 60 mille très sociaux dans le
mandat qui vient ensuite bloqué et les
prix des logements réguler les prix des
logements
comme nous l'avons fait à paris comme ça
a été fait aussi à lille et rennes est
en passe ou en tous les cas et aussi
demandeurs de cela dans les zones très
tendues où les loyers augmentent et
enfin mettre en place aussi ce que j'ai
appelé un bouclier logement pour
qu'aucun français né à dépenser plus de
30 % de ses revenus en logements donc
c'est une allocation logement une sorte
d'appel compensatrice que je met
également en place et sur la question de
ces gens parce que là elle n'est pas
propriétaire elle
s'expliquer aujourd'hui quand on est
jeune qu'on veut louer on nous demande
énormément de choses c'est comment faire
pour faciliter l'accès au logement sur
le plan financier bien évidemment mais
aussi sur le plan des démarches bien sûr
d'abord comme je les 10,1 en créant plus
de logement parce que cet effondrement
de l'offre de normand du temps ça prend
du temps ça prendra d'autant plus de
temps que sous ce quinquennat macron ça
a été totalement bloquée et que les
maires y compris les maires bâtisseurs
j'en suis une n'ont pas pu avancer leurs
programmes de construction ensuite bien
sûr qu'il faut aider ces jeunes je les
dis par rome la régulation des loyers et
pour les jeunes je propose
deux choses d'abord je propose un
minimum jeunesse qui aide aussi les
jeunes à pouvoir ceux qui sont en
difficulté financière
les étudiants et ô combien haut pour moi
c'est autour de 500 euros par mois et
sous conditions de ressources qui
permettra à ces jeunes d'avancé ce n'est
pas ça ne vient pas retirer quoi que ce
soit du côté des apl il y à ce que j'ai
dit sur cet appel compensatrice de
bouclier logement que je propose et puis
bien sûr il ya aussi une aide enfin un
capital que je veux proposer à chaque
jeune de 18 ans de 5000 euros qui peut
lui permettre aussi bien sûr de porter
un projet mais pourquoi pas de pouvoir
aussi faire les démarches à porter les
cautions les garanties nécessaires
lorsqu'il a besoin de se loger pour
prendre son autonomie anne hidalgo c'est
une tradition dans cette émission
dessinateur et collaborateurs de
ouest-france chaunu à une question à
vous poser sous forme de dessin
le général de gaulle a institué le
système des parrainages pour empêcher
les candidatures fantaisistes à
l'élection présidentielle françois
hollande lui à lever l'anonymat pour
éviter que le diable n'arrive à l'elysée
bon enfin voilà notre pays traverse une
grave crise de la représentation
démocratique
l'abstention progresse à chaque élection
peut-on imaginer
madame la maire qu'une candidate et plus
de signatures
que des lecteurs
d'abord vous savez c'est une règle
démocratique qui est ancienne et sur
laquelle
le parti socialiste a fait une
proposition il y a un an à l'assemblée
qui était de modifier cette règle
il était proposé 250 parrainage et il
était proposé aussi qu'il puisse y avoir
150 mille électeurs qui soutiennent une
candidature ce qui me paraissait une
très bonne règle ça a été refusé par le
gouvernement actuel donc c'est très bien
une semaine avant la fin des parrainages
de se poser la question et de crier au
scandale démocratique
vous savez franchement c'est le coup
nous est fait à chaque élection et on va
être encore les idiots utiles de ceux
qui nous font ce coup là si on n'est pas
foutu pardon mais de recueillir 500
signatures sur quarante deux mille
personnes qui donnent ces signatures
alors c'est qu'il ya un problème je lai
et heureusement que je les ai et ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya un
enracinement ça veut dire qu'il ya un
ancrage les élus qui donnent leurs
parrainages qu'est-ce qu'ils font une
prennent une responsabilité politique et
devant leurs électeurs vous croyez que
ça c'est un acte qu'on peut balayer du
revers d'une main en disant c'est pas
démocratique c'est pas démocratique
d'avoir des maires qui sont là qui
s'engagent et qui accepte parce qu'ils
ne sont pas dans l'anonymat de défendre
une position y compris pour le pays
qu'on arrête qu'on arrête franchement on
nous refait le coup systématiquement et
puis moi je veux empêcher personne
d'avoir comparé nages j'ai vraiment
péché personne n'a compris le parrainage
mais je dis que la démocratie souffre de
ne pas avoir quelqu'un condamné pour
racisme et qui tient des propos
négationnistes toute la journée sur les
ondes il ya peut-être un petit problème
démocratique a laissé ce type de parole
se diffuser comme elle se diffuse
aujourd'hui la une de ouest france
franck labeyrie l'offrant là une
nouvelle france eh bien c'est l'ukraine
et d'ukraine ça veut dire ce matin la
guerre en europe ni quand même ça et
puis la question aussi du prix de
l'énergie parce que ce soit pour ce sera
un des sujets forts de cette campagne
c'est quelque chose qui pèse évidemment
dans le budget de m le marché de
l'énergie restera tendu merci françois
développement de ouest france dans un
instant denis carot de nice matin sur
ses plateaux
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot merci d'être avec
nous dans un hôtel besoin vous
interviewez anne hidalgo à mes côtés
tout de suite on se rend aux antilles
anne hidalgo ziri boutiques et directeur
éditorial de france antilles notre
partenaire dans cette émission une
question à vous poser depuis
fort-de-france en écoute bonjour anne
hidalgo lors de votre récent déplacement
aux antilles vous avez appelé à
davantage écouter les territoires qui
vous l'avez dit connaissent leurs forces
et leurs faiblesses alors si vous êtes
élue présidente de la république quelle
sera votre première mesure votre mesure
phare en faveur des outre-mer je les dis
les outre-mers aujourd'hui souffrent
vraiment de dinde un retard
d'accompagner revenir mesure la première
mesure c'est soutenir l'école et
soutenir l'hôpital réparer l'école et
l'hôpital permettre aussi à nos
compatriotes d outre-mer de martinique
et de guadeloupe qui ont été contaminés
par le chlordécone de pouvoir bénéficier
de tous les soins gratuits y compris
pour le dépistage et puis engager aussi
sur la question notamment des sargasses
une politique qui permette notamment à
nos compatriotes d outre-mer de ne pas
souffrir d'un nouveau scandale
environnemental et sanitaire voilà les
sargasses ce sont ces algues qui vient
dans une évolué et sur la couenne sur la
santé sur la bonne ne fait pas dans
denis caron anne hidalgo une bonne
nouvelle pour commencer 8 jeunes sur 10
envisagent d'aller voter selon un
sondage sopra steria pour la fage qui a
été publiée hier ce qui est plus
préoccupant c'est que les deux tiers de
ces jeunes considèrent que les
politiques ne s'intéressent pas à leurs
préoccupations alors vous êtes et les
politiques sont déconnectés des jeunes
je ne crois pas être déconnecté des
jeunes est justement vous savez cette
france des territoires que je représente
cette équipe de france des mers
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait toute la journée
elle apporte des solutions à la jeunesse
qui s'est impliqué sur les questions
environnementales
je me suis impliqué sur ces questions
environnementales quand j'ai vu que les
jeunes étaient effectivement demandeur
qu'il y ait des lieux où ils puissent
saisir eux-mêmes des solutions pour
demain qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai créé
une académie
du climat à paris je pose des actes et
on n'est pas déconnecté en revanche ce
qui est très important et ce que je veux
dire aux jeunes c'est que s'ils veulent
peser dans les décisions politiques il
faut qu'ils se saisissent en effet du
bulletin de vote il faut qu'ils se
saisissent de cette possibilité de
réorienter la démocratie vous savez
beaucoup de politique c'est pas mon cas
mais beaucoup de politiques considèrent
que puisque les jeunes ne votent pas et
bien finalement c'est pas la peine de
les écouter parce que c'est pas une
clientèle électorale et bien da partir
du moment où ils montreront leur volonté
de voter je vous assure je vous assure
que vous serez écouter en tous les cas
sur les questions environnementales
comme sur les questions sociales parce
que les jeunes portent cette générosité
et cette volonté aussi d'une société
plus égalitaire
nos rages les écoutes et qu'ils lisent
mon programme alors j'ai réagi car
j'aime bien mon programme est en phase
avec justement sur le détail du
programme je voudrais revenir sur une
mesure que vous avez évoquées avec
françois xavier le franc tout à l'heure
c'est cette somme de 5000 euros y
allouer à chaque jeune dès l'âge de 18
ans alors quel est l'objectif est aussi
est-ce que c'est sans la moindre
condition c'est à dire absolument pour
tout le monde quel que soit le niveau de
revenu et la situation sans condition de
ressources parce que je veux vraiment
que cette aide elle aille vers tous les
jeunes et y compris les jeunes de la
classe moyenne
quand vous mettez des conditions de
ressources en général les jeunes de la
toulousaine la compréhension écartée à
quoi ça servira on les accompagnera dans
l'élaboration de leur projet mais c'est
5000 euros ça peut servir à quoi un
jeune en territoire plus rurale peut
avoir besoin de passer son permis de
conduire parce que il aura besoin
évidemment de se déplacer qui a pas de
transports en commun un jeune qui va
engager sa vie étudiante aura besoin
sans doute aussi d'un équipement
informatique qui lui permettent d'aller
vers ces des risques perdurent à un
accompagnement ou c'est simplement une
somme cette somme de 5000 euros
il se pose comme il comme il le souhaite
chacun pourra en disposer comme il le
souhaite mais bien sûr qu'on va
accompagner les jeunes pour que cette
somme là il puisse la mettre à profit
aussi d'un voyage à l'étranger
2 de la création d'une association avec
d'autres moi j'ai confiance dans les
jeunes vous savez quand on a dit qu'on
allait supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune
c'est quand même quatre à cinq milliards
d'euros sur le budget de l'état personne
n'a dit comment va accompagner ceux qui
payent l'impôt sur la fortune pour que
il fasse bon usage des sommes qu'on
l'aura laissé libre donc voilà on va les
accompagner mais franchement franchement
il faut quand même qu'on leur fasse
toujours sur le jeu sur les jeunes et
sur l'éducation une de vos propositions
c'est la suppression de parcours sur wii
elle ce système qui permet de préparer
l'après bac pourquoi vous le supprimer
et surtout pourquoi vous le remplacer je
lis au crime parce que c'est un système
vraiment extrêmement violent qui met en
stress tous les jeunes c'est un
algorithme un système très opaque qui
dessert la ligne est offert et qui vous
oriente vers des choses qui ne vous
intéresse peut-être même pas du tout
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à
la presse un système de d'orientation
que je mets en place dès la 4eme
d'accompagnement tout au long de la
formation du jeune de la ive jusqu'à la
terminale et même jusqu'à bac + 3 parce
que les jeunes ils peuvent avoir à un
moment donné d'abord ne pas savoir ce
qu'ils veulent faire ils peuvent avoir
envie d'aller sur une voie et
s'apercevoir qu'elle n'est pas bonne et
je mets en place aussi quelque chose qui
me paraît très important qui est la
généralisation des formations en
alternance
après le bac parce que je pense que nos
jeunes ont besoin y compris pour aller
vers l'enseignement supérieur d'avoir un
rapport avec le monde professionnel avec
le monde des adultes est plutôt que
d'avoir un petit boulot qui n'a rien à
voir avec son avec son diplôme et qui
souvent d'ailleurs va venir contredire
dans le concret dans le temps a aussi
dans le concret des apprentissages
théoriques indispensable mais aussi
d'être beaucoup plus dans le concret
nice matin anne hidalgo a rencontré
michel lottier qui est maire de plo
d'ascq dans les alpes maritimes
denis carreaux et les chasseurs il est
une catégorie très bien je suis chasseur
aujourd'hui le monde va chasser
cruellement touchée
est concerné devant ces accidents rangs
serrés qu'il va falloir que l'on modifie
que en améliore l'information
mais ce que je voulais savoir de votre
part madame c est ce que vous avez les
idées de monsieur jeannot et de monsieur
mélenchon brrr aussi faibles que leurs
programmes
le qui est de détruire à la chasse
je voudrais savoir vos idées sur la
sécurité future et sur la chasse que
vous semblez dessinée merci madame
d'abord je considère que la chasse dans
notre pays c'est aussi une culture une
tradition qu'il faut réguler qu'il faut
mieux encadrer les accidents que l'on a
vu son terrible ça ne peut pas durer il
faut absolument y compris sur la nature
des fusils leurs portes et que l'on ait
des réglementations et des formations
réguler ça pourrait être mettre en place
ne serait-ce qu'un jour sans chasse un
gouvernement socialiste qui l'avait fait
en 2000 oui ça peut aimer dans la
discussion tous les cas je ne suis pas
sur l'idée qu'il faudrait condamner il
faudrait interdire la chasse à courre et
ce type de challes corridor évidemment
des ascendants moi je vraiment je le
spectacle de la corrida est quelque
chose qui est vraiment de la violence
faite sur les animaux qui est
extrêmement choquant mais je pense que
sur la chasse beaucoup de régulation
beaucoup de négociations beaucoup de
discussions et c'est comme ça qu'on
avancera pas dans le village de
nice-matin le nikkor la une de nice
matin une grid bettencourt l'ex otage
des farc a accordé une interview
n'exclut exclusive au groupe nice matin
vingt ans après son enlèvement elle est
candidate à l'élection présidentielle en
colombie vous soutenez cette candidature
mais je connais bien une grille de béton
entourage me suis beaucoup mobilisé pour
sa libération
je ne sais pas ce qu'elle propose donc
je connais bien la colombie aussi et la
colombie est un pays qui a besoin de
démocratie
je suis très proche du président santos
avec lequel j'ai souvent des échanges et
il est aujourd'hui
vraiment ils et prix nobel de la paix
aussi pour avoir réussi notamment cette
négociation et ses sorties de conflit
avec les farc denis carot il sera
atteint dans un instant armelle le goff
du journal 20 minutes
[Musique]
bon joueur mais le goal merci d'être
avec nous alors la politique de la ville
des territoires ça vous concerne j'ai
vingt minutes oui et j'avais une
première question d'abord est ce que
vous êtes venus en voiture électrique ce
matin oui absolument en voiture
électrique je me déplace beaucoup aussi
en métro à pied en vélo mais là ce matin
c'était la voiture et explique je vous
pose cette question parce que vous
annoncez dans votre programme vouloir
installer un million de bornes de
recharge électrique et encourager les
petites lignes ferroviaires et les
trains de nuit est ce que vous pensez
que ces mesures sont suffisantes pour
véritablement améliorer la mobilité des
français je pense qu'il faut dans mes
propositions j'ai une grande odyssée
industriels sur la mobilité je pense que
la france peut être d'ailleurs sur le
terrain industriel et de l'innovation
une des grandes nations qui change la
donne en matière de mobilité mobilité
électrique mobilité hydrogène mobilité
en augmentant justement la part des
transports en commun et de ses lignes
ferroviaires qu'on a abandonné et qui
ont été totalement délaissé pour
décaisser dernières années des questions
et qui'il mais les bouts de chair mais
en fait vous voyez bien que finalement
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher de fermer
des lignes parce que vous mettez des
gens en situation de dépendance que la
voiture ça coûte cher que l'essence ça
coûte encore plus cher aux joueurs ayant
justement à la reprise vous venez de
repousser à 2024 l'interdiction du
trafic de transit dans le centre de la
capitale en fait c'est pas possible non
c'est pas du tout repoussé c'est nous
tenons compte des demandes de la haute
autorité environnementale qui nous
demande de prendre ce temps de
discussion et de concertation donc je
respecte simplement le calendrier qui le
calendrier des procédures que nous
devons engager parce que j'ai toujours
dit j'ai toujours c'est comme ça fait en
fonction de la loi donc on ne repousse
pas du tout mais on reste que la loire
cette question de la mobilité la crise
des gilet jaune c'était aussi une crise
du transport du droit au transport
individuel pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens la voiture c'est aussi une
expérience de liberté c'est quelque
chose qui a théorisé le philosophe
michael fausse elle dans son livre
quartier rouge pour comment vous
appréhendez c'est justement ce besoin de
liberté qui s'exprime à travers le fait
de prendre sa voiture de façon très
pragmatique il ya des territoires dans
lesquels aujourd'hui
question de la voiture n'est même plus
un sujet de liberté regarder dans les
grandes villes les jeunes ne passent
plus leurs permis de conduire parce que
ils estiment qu'ils en ont pas besoin
quand ils ont d'autres possibilités en
revanche il y à des territoires où c'est
indispensable c'est indispensable parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre moyen de bouger
donc il faut avoir une politique très
pragmatique appuyé sur les régions sur
les communes les départements
qui tienne compte de ces disparités de
terry soif vous venez par exemple la p1
yalgo par la politique que vous avez
menée à paris éclaté tout pas du tout
est totalement asphyxiée nain moi même
je suis refait un moto franchise comment
vous pouvez dire deux choses pareilles
on le vit tous les noms en faute
campagne même dit à un moment donné que
ce sont les papiers des jaunes à bord
pharisiens écouter parisien réélu je
suis pas en campagne pour les élections
municipales et rurales vers les basses
campagne non ça ne laisse pas au
contraire parce que vous avez l'air
agacé des comptes non non simplement de
ça je suis pas du tout agacé simplement
il ya un problème vous le reconnaissez
non d'hadrons connaissent aucun problème
de cette lotion pas les écouter j'ai été
réélu peut-être que ça vous a échappé je
ne suis pas un candidat tenant
candidates à l'élection de la mairie de
paris donc je parle aux françaises et
aux français mario jouer je suis
comptable notamment d'être une des
responsables politiques qui se soit le
plus engagé pour diminuer la pollution
atmosphérique dans notre pays et qui est
reconnue l'ont dépeint à l'international
et qui est reconnu et la circulation à
paris comme dans les grandes villes est
une circulation qui ne peut plus se
faire part aujourd'hui pop mais enfin
vous êtes en train de ramener le sujet
sur paris je suis en train de vous dire
depuis le début qu'il faut différencier
évoquant les territoires le faisons
aujourd'hui surnom el présidentielle
auditivement dans la mesure où je suis
une des responsables politiques les
banlieues engagé les plus engagés à fond
sur les questions de mobilité vous non
mais je veux revenir parce que du coup
je n'ai pas pu dire ce que je proposais
pour les français qui ne peuvent pas
faire autrement que de prendre leur
voiture eh bien je propose plusieurs
choses d'abord oui ce grand plan sur les
infrastructures notamment connaissent
comprenant les bornes électriques mais
surtout une aide une aide qui est du
leasing social pour permettre à nos
compatriotes qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
autrement que d'avoir une voiture pour
se déplacer
pour aller au travail de pouvoir
bénéficier de ce désigne social au prix
d'un véhicule thermique pour des
véhicules électriques ou des véhicules
hydrogène et je vous le dis je vous le
redis tout responsable politique qui
aujourd'hui viendrez vous expliquer que
la question de la pollution de l'air de
la transition énergétique qui
considérait que la place du moteur
thermique serait encore dans nos
perspectives industrielles
vous ferez faire un bond en arrière moi
je regarde l'avenir et vous parliez tout
à l'heure des jeunes je crois que les
jeunes approuve le plus tôt c'est la
politique les ramène le goff notre
actionnaire du groupe centre france la
montagne
aujourd'hui c'est alexandre charrier de
la république du centre à une question à
vous poser on écoute
bonjour anne hidalgo vous dit
aujourd'hui prête à revenir sur la loi
travail votée en 2016 sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande ma
question est double donc quel autre
domaine vous êtes prête à exercer votre
droit d'inventaire et plus globalement
est-ce que vous jugez que la gauche a
été au rendez vous pendant ses cinq
années au pouvoir oui la gauche a été au
rendez vous pendant ses cinq années au
pouvoir elle a permis de grandes
avancées de grandes conquêtes la
retraite notamment des grandes avancées
sociales et sociétales sur la loi
travail je l'avais dit d'ailleurs sous
le quinquennat de françois hollande je
pense que cette loi aurait dû plutôt
porté sur la protection par exemple des
travailleurs des plateformes que de
retirer un certain nombre de protections
je pense notamment à la question de
l'accès aux prud'hommes donc je
reviendrai sur ces sujets là je
rétablirai aussi par exemple le comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité des conditions
de travail dans dans le droit cette
dernière question d'en faire un
programme vous fait le constat d'un
régime à bout de souffle que certains
chercheurs ont théorisé en parlant de
pratiques démocratiques à 20minutes on
travaille avec une communauté de
lecteurs qui sont âgés de 18 à 30 ans
qu'on interroge avec l'institut
opinionway est effectivement parmi eux
40 % disent que un autre régime d'autres
régimes peuvent être aussi bon que la
démocratie qu'est ce que vous pensez de
nord je me sens chez moi voilà il faut
faire attention bien sûr qu'un autre
régime plus qui respire une démocratie
plus parlementaire - monarchique un
président qui décide pas tout seul de
tout un parlement qui joue son rôle des
citoyens qui peuvent intervenir
directement par un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou par exemple
par des amendements citoyens dans le
processus législatif tout ça c'est ce
que je porte dans cette campagne mais
attention
remplacer la démocratie et la république
par quoi par des régimes autoritaires
il y en a des régimes autoritaires dans
le monde vous les voyez fonctionnaires
regarder ce qui se passe en russie avec
poutine regarder ce qui se passe en
chine non en dehors de la démocratie qui
est sans doute très imparfaite il n'y a
pas de régime qui permette une de vivre
ensemble et de vivre ensemble dans la
paix et dans le respect de nos
différences de 20 minutes la une de
20minutes justement c'est sûr à
l'actualité convient avec la russie avec
les sanctions et les conséquences pour
les entreprises françaises et puis une
interview de la chanteuse fiche bas qui
sort un album ce vendredi voilà merci en
mal le goff directrice de la rédaction
de 20 minutes dans un instant des
maîtres korkmaz de tébessa
[Musique]
bonjour des mêmes fonctions on revient
sur le jour oui on revient sur l'ukraine
vous avez parlé d'unité des européens
ils nécessitaient vous avez parlé aussi
de la nécessité d'aider l'ukraine
militairement mais au-delà de ça
concrètement qu'est ce que vous proposez
déjà c'est une proposition puisque la
valeur des envois d'hommes sur place au
sol et ça maintenant
d'aider militairement l'ukraine ça veut
dire aider l'ukraine à avoir un armement
qui lui permettent de se défendre et
cette décision là elle doit pouvoir être
prises au niveau européen à 27 et elle
est indispensable pour que effectivement
on ne soit pas simplement spectateur et
dénonçant ce qui se passe et cette
guerre et cette agression terrible du
président claudy militaire c'est sûr
maintenant de l'argent nier c'est de
l'argent c'est des armes
défensives et offensives offensive qui
doivent permettre bien sûr à l'ukraine
de se défendre et la deuxième chose
c'est vous voyez bien si si on en est là
et c'est un sujet majeur à la fois je
pense de tournant dans notre campagne
présidentielle mais aussi un sujet
majeur pour l'europe évidemment il faut
ce qui manque aujourd'hui à l'europe
c'est cette europe de la défense et moi
je fais partie de ces candidats pro
européens qui veulent que cette robe en
dollar une forme à ce qu'on en dise
comment on est bien comme en ce moment
ça se construit d'abord en respectant
ses partenaires en travaillant avec ses
partenaires en faisant une avancée je
pense qu'aujourd'hui l'allemagne est
prête à cela et dans le rapport entre la
france et l'allemagne il y à cette
possibilité et d'autres pays au nombre
de nous montrent qu'ils sont frères a
avancé on n'aura pas de propositions
concrètes dont on va passer maintenant
je vais pas vous laisser dire ça si je
ne sais pas et sinon l'image maillot
aujourd'hui sonne avoir eu un rapport
qui va non non non des sujets graves non
je ne peux pas du tout à fait laisser
dire ça vous ces investigations les et
de l'office either de la razer exemple
les effectifs jeu des membres des états
membres de l'union vous faites des
questions et les réponses c'est très
bien mais je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire ça c'est quand même pas normal de
dire ça je suis totalement engagé
auprès justement de nos alliés ukrainien
et qui doit s'engager pour les soutenir
c'est l'europe l'europe doit s'engager
comment en fournissant jeu les armes ça
c'est un pas supplémentaire par rapport
à ce qui a été dit juste jusqu'à présent
fournir les armes permettant à l'ukraine
de pouvoir se défendre
il faut mettre cette pression sur
vladimir poutine et notamment mettre la
pression aussi à partir des sanctions
économiques faire avancer l'europe de la
défense ça veut dire quoi avoir une
vraie europe de la défense qui pèse face
aux crises à venir et j'ai ajouté un
autre point en début d'émission qui est
de dire il faut aussi se préparer en
france aux conséquences que va avoir
notamment la l'embargo sur le gaz qui
s'il est mis à exécution par poutine en
anticipant et en prenant les mesures ici
interne permettant de bloquer les prix
de l'énergie pour que nos compatriotes
français né pense à lorient alors voilà
ce que nous gardons mais je pense que
c'est suffisamment concret vous voulez
aussi une plus grande solidarité avec
les pays du sud et la pandémie a montré
ce manque de solidarité vous voulez que
les laboratoires lève les brevets et
expliquez nous comment vous allez vous y
prendre pour faire pression sur les
laboratoires pour que ces brevets soit
levée il faut faire pression d'abord
parce que la voix de la france est une
voie importante est que aujourd'hui le
président français ne s'est pas engagée
dans cette direction-là faire pression
avec les instances internationales les
autorités internationales je pense à
l'onu qui est exactement dans cette même
ces lots aimé jacquet qu'on paie c'est
l'om sait qui est compétente mais l'onu
joue un rôle mais aussi un rôle enfin si
l'onu n'a pas de rôle dans la parole
qu'elle comporte en terme pour les
brevets madame hidalgo c'est l'om c est
comment on lève les brevets j'écoutais
chère madame l'onu pour moi un rôle en
60 km où l'om loic et des oeufs a aussi
un rôle de pression vis-à-vis de l'om
sait et je crois que la france doit
tenir les aussi réunir l'ensemble des
fabricants de médicaments comment
comment vous croyez qu'on a réussi à
avancer par exemple sur la question du
sida et de la levée des brevets du sida
comment vous comment vous croyez qu'on a
avancé sur ce domaine là à l'époque
c'était le président lula qui a pris une
décision au brésil de l'inde et de youri
jour bruxelles on se les bois de pouvoir
développer complètement les médicaments
alors vers sa population et la bouger
quoi ça fait bouger les rssil des pays
du de la planète à travers une instance
qui s'appelle l'onu sida donc vous voyez
c'est pas faire si simple de dire
combien tout ça ne sert à rien à jm r
samedi jaya jadis par les niveaux d'eau
à l'échelle 1 alors tionale sa route il
a dominé notamment la merci des
médicaments escarmouches qui est le
directeur de l'information de notre
partenaire tv 78 dans les yvelines à une
question politique a proposé en écoute
pourtant de cuir chère anne hidalgo je
vous la vous je souffre pour vous si
votre score avoisine les 5 % un peu plus
un peu moins ce n'est pas seulement
votre image qui sera écornée c'est celle
de la capitale qui sera abîmée et vous
ne pourrez plus rester maire de paris
alors je vous pose la question qu'est ce
que vous êtes allé faire dans cette
galère vous pensez s'attendre et êtes
très très gentil de prendre soin de moi
en fait vous avez 5 ans maintenant
absolument pas ce n'est pas vous savez
je suis une femme politique une
responsable politique quand on est un
responsable politique on s'engage on
s'engage à quoi à faire bouger les
choses apporter ses convictions et je le
fais pourquoi parce que je pense que
notre pays a besoin a besoin d'une voix
et d'action aussi de gauche de cette
gauche républicaine de cette gauche de
gouvernement et que notre pays ne serait
pas tout à fait le même s'il n'avait pas
vers cette parole etc d'action met donc
merci je me porte bien et j'ai sans
doute se pose la question quels sont vos
rapports avec bertrand delanoë dont vous
savez première adjointe j'sais pas voilà
c'est quelqu'un pour lequel j'ai à me
voir je respecte pas fâché
personnellement non lui peut l'être je
n'en sais rien et vous savez c'est pas
le sujet d'une émission de télévision du
tout non pas savoir comment vous qui
avait été sa première adjointe et bien
je fais aujourd'hui je le moi je la
perds joueurs quant à l'homme quelqu'un
que j'admire pour lequel j'ai énormément
d'affection et de respect voilà je peux
vous parler de mon point de vue mais une
campagne dure pour vous monsieur non non
je vis une campagne très engagé dans
laquelle je pense que notre pays subit
tellement de crise une crise écologique
une crise économique et une crise
démocratique qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
voix forte et solide je suis une femme
solide d'une femme forte qui porte cette
voie pour servir mon pays merci mr a
bien d'algues au maire de paris
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
merci dé m korkmaz on se retrouve jeudi
prochain sur tv5 monde pour face aux
territoires les programmes continuer sur
la chaîne au revoir à tous
[Musique]